well here in germany coronavirus cases
are soaring past previous records 52 000
new covert 19 infections were reported
on wednesday there's no end in sight for
the country's fourth wave and health
experts are calling for tighter
restrictions bavaria has rolled out new
rules allowing only the vaccinated and
recently recovered to enter bars
restaurants and cultural venues but it's
not just unvaccinated people who have to
change their plans
the day began with them decking their
stalls with lights and gifts
traders at the munich christmas market
had high hopes for the season ahead
we're ready for the guests and happy if
someone comes
but by lunchtime it was off
the mayor pulled the plug
citing the rising number of covered 19
infections
following last year's cancellation the
news especially hard to take in
i'm obviously completely shocked i
didn't expect that after the positive
signs coming out of other cities
it's not good it's quite a big loss for
us for sure but what can you do it's
just a shame that we didn't find out
earlier
the move comes on the back of a de facto
lockdown for the unvaccinated
here's why the region's health care
system is at breaking point the majority
of patients unvaccinated
you see the numbers every morning and
you think this can't be true and we feel
a little bit like the cleaning mop of
the country here
in berlin a leading virologist warned
mps that restricting unvaccinated people
from public life
might not be enough
i think you have to think about how to
introduce here an additional layer of
protection for those who are not
vaccinated and can be infected in
private areas and from experience that's
about group size and about the freedom
to meet
the crisis comes as the three parties
locked in talks to form a new government
entered the next stage of negotiations
though stopped short of proposing any
new pandemic measures
we expect to have a draft coalition
agreement next week
thoroughness comes before speed
progress maybe but of little help to
those staking their livelihoods on life
returning to normal
our political correspondent benjamin
alvarez gruber is in munich and joins us
now benjamin munich pulled uh pulled the
plug on its traditional christmas market
at the last minute that decision cannot
have been taken lightly what does that
tell us about the situation there at the
moment
good morning rebecca i think there are
two points that we have to make here on
one side it shows how severe the
situation is in bavaria state premier
marcus suiter said that this is the week
of truth after declaring a state
emergency state of emergency in bavaria
in germany's second most populous state
and the state of emergency will allow
also to a faster management to avoid
exactly what health
care workers are warning about it is a
collapse of the hospitals or of the
his system here in bavaria and on the
other side it shows also the frustration
of vendors who were also still working
trying to close in their souls that they
installed here yesterday
and they are really sad and disappointed
not only by the fact that it was
cancelled it was cancelled last year as
well but last year they were told in
november that the christmas markets
would not take place and this time it
was only five times five days before
this christmas market was scheduled to
open so of course they are really
disappointed this time now germany is of
course rolling out the third covert
booster shot across the country what's
the uptake been like
yesterday there was a pretty long queue
right next to the town hall where we're
standing right now with people trying to
get either the first the second or the
third shot so there were many people
interested and of course there are
professionals warning that there should
be also at least a priority list to
avoid what happened sometimes with the
first draft that people who are not um
were not first in line to get the job
actually get it german health minister
yen span said that there are enough
booster vaccines
that germany even delayed the delivery
of vaccines through this kovacs a
program to have enough vaccines here so
now authorities also try to increase the
number of people that not only get the
boosted job now but also the first and
the second one with a vaccination rate
that has not reached 70 percent in
germany
what are people telling you about how
they feel about this imminent or this
happening fourth wave it's upon us uh
how do they feel about it and how do
they feel about the new restrictions
well of course all of them are really
tired but they are not keen on more
restrictions the nurse told us on the
other side that it's needed that we need
more restrictions as well bavaria now
has stricter rules when it comes to
visiting restaurant when it comes to
going to hotels but what is also needed
is that authorities and also the people
who work in these restaurants actually
check these career passes that people
have been fully vaccinated have to show
them that they're able to go into the
restaurant so there's one side and also
what people are asking what they've been
asking for since the outbreak of the
pandemic here in germany
is to have rules on a national level of
course states can have their own rules
but it's a big problem here in germany
because we have a patchwork of
restrictions in some states you have
these rules in other states you have
other rules so people know that the
situation is serious that local and
state authorities are trying to do
everything that they can also to avoid a
collapse of the health system of the
hospitals but they're also asking for
rules that apply for everyone in germany
and not depending on the state where
they are in that moment all right
benjamin thank you benjamin alvarez
gruber in munich for us
let's get more now from tobias curt he's
the director of the institute of public
health at the charity hospital here in
berlin dr kurt thanks for speaking to dw
now two-thirds of the german population
are vaccinated but we're seeing record
new infections almost daily are you
surprised by that
no unfortunately not not so there are
still not enough people vaccinated that
a
wave a so-called fourth wave that we're
having right now would not happen with
that massive numbers also we know that
the immune system
is is not
really completely protected after the
second vaccination so
it will it will go down and that's why
we're having the booster vaccination so
that's important and if you are
vaccinated it doesn't mean that you
cannot be infected there's a certain
chance that you still get infected and
you can transmit the virus to others so
unfortunately no i'm not surprised by
these high numbers
now you said that germany's struggle
with the pandemic last winter was
because of the sluggish political
response what do you see as the cause of
this fourth wave
i think there are several courses so
many things coming together as as i just
said but also that there is a lack and
decision making if we had reacted for
six weeks ago with the so-called 2g
uh principle that only those vaccinated
are able to go into public spaces or in
restaurants that would that may have
been enough now it's it's unfortunately
too late so i'm afraid that there will
be other measures in the next few days
or weeks one of germany's leading
virologists says restricting
unvaccinated people in public life might
be enough and he says restrictions on
private gatherings might be called for
do you agree with that statement
unfortunately we don't have much choices
left uh to break the wave so we have
we're seeing dramatic numbers in germany
the healthcare system is over its limits
in many regions already in germany so we
have to do something and because people
waited or decision makers wait it's so
long to do anything
it won't be possible to really do it
without these restrictions unfortunately
now a
few people expected germany to be in
this situation again this winter
vaccinations seem to be stalling at
around that 67
mark what will it take to turn the page
on the virus
well i think people really have to get
vaccinated we need to have to boost
booster vaccination for those who are
above 60 for sure likely also for those
above 18
so we need to keep on vaccinating and
by this i hope that the fourth wave can
be stopped at least hold at this point
and and then it's like it's a common
effort it will remain a common effort as
there are sufficient people who are
still be possible to get infected as
long we will see another wave coming in
the future
so vaccination certainly the way out of
this pandemic all right to be as curt
from the charity hospital
thank you very much for your insights
thank you for having me
singapore is also experiencing its worst
cove at 19 waves since the start of the
pandemic reporting around 2 000 cases a
day that has since it abandoned its zero
covid strategy now singapore needs to
get more people vaccinated to reduce the
strain on the health care system so it's
making life potentially more expensive
for the unvaccinated
in singapore getting a job is not just
going to save lives soon it could also
save people money
until now the government has covered the
medical costs for most coveted patients
but starting december the 8th anyone
unvaccinated by choice will have to pay
their own bills
our hospitals really much prefer
not to have to build these patients at
all
but we have to send this important
signal
to urge everyone to get vaccinated if
you are eligible
with 85 percent of singapore's
population fully inoculated health
officials say it's the unvaccinated who
make up a sizable majority of covet
intensive care patients
the country is experiencing its worst
wave of the pandemic as it moves its
strategy from zero covet to coexisting
with the virus
we will need to have safe management
measures
which differentiate between the
vaccinated and unvaccinated this is in
order to protect the unvaccinated and
also to preserve our healthcare capacity
prior to the planned hospital charges
the government had already introduced
restrictions for unvaccinated
individuals preventing them from dining
indoors going to shopping malls or
visiting attractions
for anyone still considering whether to
get a jab or not the high cost of an
infection just might make the difference
we can speak now to dale fisher he's a
public health professor in singapore and
he's joining us today uh from geneva
dale good to have you with us what do
you make of the strategy in singapore to
make the unvaccinated pay for their
hospital treatment
yeah you've said it right it's it's
exactly that it's it's another strategy
we know that the unvaccinated are more
vulnerable we know they're more
transmissible
we know they make up uh
the majority of the patients that need
hospitalization so in singapore even
though
94 of the eligible are actually
vaccinated that six percent of people
still
is quite a sizable number so so they're
the ones putting
putting stress on the system so
singapore has tried
uh many things uh mostly educational and
and and also differentiated measures
such as uh they're not allowed to go to
to hawker stalls and things like that
and because of these still tens of
thousands of people that are putting a
stress on the health care system it's
it's as of december 8 there's going to
be
a charge singapore's got a very
subsidized universal health system so
uh the the threat which hopefully won't
be enforced uh is that uh sick people
that have chosen to be unvaccinated will
won't be able to take advantage of the
subsidy well dale there is a debate
right now in germany over a vaccine
mandate i mean is that something that
would be considered in singapore or
anywhere in asia
well i'm certainly a fan of mandating it
it's it's right up there with seatbelts
as far as i'm concerned that these
vaccines save lives and help countries
return to normal but it's a it's a
political decision and singapore has
been been very reluctant for for any
mandating as indeed most has most of the
world so
so we have these if you like
pseudo mandates by making life
difficult through through various
carrots and stick measures
dale just very quickly there seems to be
a shift away from the zero covet
strategy that we saw originally in
singapore is there an understanding a
realization that we have to live with
the virus
oh yeah that's not new uh it's clear
that uh coverts not going anywhere so
it's about how do you move from a
situation where you kept the numbers
very small and the deaths uh virtually
rare right now introducing it yeah
we'll have to leave it there dale fisher
public health professor and singapore
expert on covet 19. thank you so much
for joining us
in other developments in the pandemic
pfizer has announced a deal to allow
dozens of developing nations to make and
sell its experimental covert 19
treatment pill
ireland is asking people to work again
from home as it expands its booster
program covered cases and
hospitalizations are both on the rise
and new york city will allow revelers
back into times square for new year's
eve celebrations but only if they have
proof of vaccination